welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and chongqi in the legend of the 10
rings changed the game of the mcu in
ways that'll knock you sideways like
abomination versus wong spoiler warning
before we continue because i'm gonna
break down this movie's finale and post
credit scenes go watch this movie and
i'll be here to help you unpack what the
f just happened okay shongxi has two
post-credit scenes but first a quick
recap chongqi after 10 years of being
separated from his crime lord father
when wu is dragged back into the tin
rings compound alongside his sister xiao
ling when wu uses his children to find
the hidden kingdom of tallow guided by
what he thinks is the voice of his
deceased wife zheng li to rescue her
soul from a sealed cave but when wu is
actually being manipulated by an
otherworldly soul sucker beast who in
the past had been fended off by a dragon
known as the great protector when wu
unwittingly opens the seal to unleash
the mega soul sucker into the realm the
shang chi reclaims the rings from his
father and with the help of the great
protector the warriors of ta lo combined
with those of the ten rings in katy's
archery shanghi slays the monster and
all this is recap too shang chi and
katie's skeptical friends over drinks
but then my favorite party crashing
visual effect in the mcu a portal opens
and then comes wong whom we saw earlier
facing abomination in a friendly cage
fight in macau now it isn't clear but
abomination might be getting weekend
passes after he was detained following
his battle with hulk and harlem or maybe
abomination is wong's sparring partner
whom he doesn't mention to bruce banner
because the first rule of wong's fight
club is you don't talk about hanging out
with your friend's enemy anyway wong
brings shangxi and katie to the sanctum
sanctorum since they have a lot to talk
about and that brings us to our first of
two post-credit scenes wong uses his
magic to analyze the ten rings alongside
shang chi and katie while on a
conference call with captain marvel
carol danvers and bruce banner they're
on one of those hollow projection group
chats similar to the way the avengers
checked in with each other and endgame
banner looks noticeably older and he's
back in human form from his seemingly
permanent smart hulk forum from endgame
but his arm remains in a sling so the
injury he sustained from snapping the
start gauntlet which left him in a sling
in in-game's final minutes is still
affecting him physically remember the
ancient one was able to push banner's
human soul out of his hulk body so maybe
banner's return to human form was some
kind of magic offered by the sorcerers
wong and doctor strange something we
could learn more about in she-hulk along
with by the way whatever wong's
friendship with abomination is all about
or maybe something we could learn more
about in spider-man no way home since
doctor strange seems in a weird mood to
grant his avenger buddies random favors
danvers confirms that the tech isn't
chitari or any alien text she has seen
chatari of course being the warriors of
thanos army led by loki in the first
avengers movie tech that was later
repurposed by vulture's crew in
spider-man homecoming banner says the
rings aren't made of vibranium the metal
of all of black panther's tech and what
captain america's shield is made out of
and that these rings are way older than
a thousand years old now we're not too
far from winter weather and if there's
leaves on the ground there should be
vessies on your feet thanks to bessie
for sponsoring this video bessies are
the perfect everyday shoe besties are
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof whether you need to get
through snow or puddles or rivers of
pumpkin spice lattes these shoes are
keeping your socks dry and keeping you
looking good they're made with this
dimetex material that keeps your feet
warm in cold weather cool in warm
weather super easy to clean with just a
rinse of water oh plunk
my shoes got all wet but hey wouldn't
you know it thanks to these messy knit
sneakers my little piggies are bone dry
thanks
they're stretchy they fit your foot like
a sock and whatever the season these are
truly an everyday shoe besties are my
go-to shoes by my door check them out in
the link below for your own pair of
bessie shoes
now in the comics the 10 rings are
ancient alien macleon tech that crashed
to earth in a spacecraft and it was from
this wreckage that the mandarin zhengju
the character win wu is based on stole
them but in the film it said that when
wu might have found these rings in a
crater or a tomb but it is not confirmed
in comics each ring contains the soul of
a cosmic warrior and each has different
abilities abilities that are not shown
in the film all 10 rings seem to give
off the same powers of strength
enhancement and being slung as powerful
projectiles but these more mystical
qualities are explored here because wong
zooms in to show a pulsing beacon
summoning something from afar something
threatening to change the mcu as we know
it there's no going back so the question
now is who or what are these 10 rings
summoning if the mcu maintains their
mcluhan origins that threat could be
from another planet or from another
galaxy and if we're looking for ancient
beings from the stars galactus could be
on his way in the mcu you could also say
the celestials are coming because we
know they're being summoned back to
earth for some emergence in eternals but
i suspect that that movie might take
place in the seven days after end game
which might set it before chongqi
especially since that movie's release
date was supposed to be before shanxi
originally but i cannot give firm
answers on the timeline yet but i will
say based on the way this movie explored
tallow its magic and its relationship to
other realms i think this threat is more
likely to come from another dimension in
the comics talo is one of the god realms
a small pocket dimension adjacent to
earth in the film it's also the nexus
gateway to an additional realm of these
soul suckers with lovecraftian design
elements notably cthulhu or nyarlathotep
who telepathically invades mortals minds
much like this beast does to win woo you
could see it similar to how thor said in
avengers that fury's work with the
tesseract signal to all the realms that
earth is ready for a higher form of war
and this beacon could be summoning
whatever interdimensional threat that dr
strange and wong will face and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
we've speculated schuma gorath or one of
the elder gods the fact that the same
interdimensional tentacle monster just
made a second appearance in this week's
episode of what if after the pilot makes
a pretty strong case that one of these
many angled ones could be the threat on
the horizon along with perhaps other
devilish mystic entities we saw hints of
in episode four but we should also
consider c'thun the ancient demonic
author of the darkhold and in the comics
the one who first cursed one of maximoff
with her sorcery or figures like
nightmare or
mafisto whom i only bring up because it
is interesting that in this movie this
voice promised you quote your greatest
desires implying some kind of faustian
manipulation but maybe a sign that
marvel rather than going the strictly
christian biblical take on this
character as in the comics might instead
reintroduce him as a more
non-denominational evil with forms
specific to all cultures and perhaps
entities like this mega soul sucker and
dormammu in eliath and loki were all
buffer predators kept at bay by
protectors within our reality but now
that these border beasts have been
slayed and the walls have been shaken
even more dangerous predators from
beyond have arrived to exploit the
scarlet witch peter parker and loki's
destabilization of reality in the mcu in
order to feast on that madness the good
news is now shanghi will join that fight
because as carol danvers jets after an
emergency call maybe some threat she'll
have to deal with in the marvels banner
jokes how he never got danvers number i
guess only nick fury has that pager
access and they tell shang chi welcome
to the circus an informal invitation to
the avengers and shangti katy and wong
celebrate by singing karaoke including
hotel california which was katie's art
of confusion song mentioned earlier in
the movie now the second post-credits
scene catches up with zha ling whom
katie and chung chi believe to be
dismantling the ten rings after the
battle but instead she takes over her
father's throne and expands the ten
rings operation at her sides are razer
fist and john john who ran her macau
club and in front of them various aides
trade paperwork perhaps planning the
epic fighting tournament we thought we
might see in this film you'll notice
among these training warriors are a new
group of female warriors sparring with
the males and street art covering the
walls of the compound and then the title
flashes on screen the 10 rings will
return you may notice how the framing
and tone here does evoke the post-credit
scene of the mandalorian season 2 in
which boba fett usurped the throne of
jabba the hutt occupied by bib fortuna
setting up boba fett's upcoming series
the book of boba fett making me wonder
if the ten rings could appear next in a
disney plus series in which the mcu's
best warriors are matched up against
each other in a grand fighting
tournament like wong versus abomination
could have been just a taste of it baby
she-hulk vs b-15 white vision vs red
guardian a melee of all the loki
variants a melee among all the peter
parkers and the winners face off finish
them keep an eye out for my shanxi
easter egg breakdown coming tomorrow on
the new rockstars channel and you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this awesome
what if inspired design which when you
get it you'll get the added option right
in a custom shout out that will appear
on screen and are what if after shows
you can follow me on instagram and on
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you